-Congratulations on the film.
Congratulations on
your Golden Globe nomination.
-Thanks so much.
-For those who haven't seen,
this is one of the great stunt
driving films of the modern era.
And is it true that you did
some of the stunt driving?
-Yeah, I did all --
No, I did some of it.
[ Laughter ]
They didn't let me do
that much stunt driving.
-So what would they let you do,
like, parallel park?
[ Laughter ]
-No, they did not -- definitely
did not let me parallel park.
No. Just regular parking.
The problem -- So, I did
like 10 stunt driving classes.
And I actually learned how to
drive most of the stuff.
-This is before the movie
started, you put the work in.
-I put the work in. I wanted to
know how to drive like Baby.
-Yeah.
-But then when I actually
got on set,
I was like,
"Okay, what are we doing?
What are we doing?"
They said,
"You're not doing anything."
"We got Jamie Foxx in the car
and Jon Hamm in the car.
You're not doing anything."
-Right.
-You know what I mean?
And then when Jamie Foxx
and Jon Hamm weren't in the car,
then they let me do stuff.
-Oh, interesting.
-Yeah.
-So they didn't want to
risk the whole cast?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, just me.
-Just part of it, yeah.
-Yeah.
-And, well,
it certainly paid off.
You actually kept the car.
Is this true?
'Cause I don't think --
I've never heard of this.
I feel like in
the "Fast and Furious" movies,
they don't get to keep the car.
-Really? You don't think
Vin Diesel has a garage of like,
a hundred of the
"Fast and Furious" cars?
-Of course he does.
I don't know what I'm thinking.
-Totally does.
-Of course he does.
Oh, no, I saw Vin Diesel
on the bus.
Yeah. I don't think --
[ Laughter ]
So you got to keep your car.
-Yes.
-What kind of car is it?
-It's a Subaru WRX STI.
It's the one
from the opening scene.
-Gotcha.
-And I just kept begging
for them to let me have it.
Then I said, "I'll buy it.
I'll do whatever."
And I just kept following up
and e-mailing.
That's how --
if you want something in life,
you just keep following up.
[ Laughter ]
-Go get 'em.
-Yeah.
I kept e-mailing the producers
and saying,
"Hey, how about that car?
You know,
I'm willing to pay for it.
Let me get that car."
And then months later,
when it was my birthday,
about six months later,
they gave it to me.
-You wore them down.
Congratulations.
-Yeah, exactly.
-That's really nice.
-Perseverance.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, so that --
For fans of the film,
it must be an interesting thing
to see you
in the car from the movie.
-Yes.
-I mean, you know, you don't see
Christian Bale in the Batmobile.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, my other question is
do people also --
Has anybody picked up
on calling you Baby yet?
Because that is
obviously a unique name
for a main character in a film.
-Yeah, it's a little odd because
people do call me Baby now.
There's this deli around the
corner of my house in Brooklyn.
And the guys are nice
and they were always nice to me
for the first two years
that I've lived there
and gone in there.
But now, I walk in there
and this dude from Yemen is
like, "Hey, baby!"
[ Laughter ]
"What do you want? You want
the halal over rice, man?"
You know?
"Hey, Baby, come on. Make
a halal over rice for Baby."
[ Laughter ]
-Nothing would make me happier
than if you found out
he's never seen the film.
[ Laughter ]
He just -- That after --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Basically, like, hey,
you know...
Anyone -- it turns out anyone
that goes there for two years,
he just feels comfortable enough
with them
to finally start
calling them Baby.
-Yeah. Could be.
-Jamie Foxx,
one of your cast members --
cast mates of the show --
uh, film.
He would deejay on set.
This film is so tied to music.
But he would actually deejay
in between takes.
Is that when he would do it?
-Yeah.
So, Jamie does deejay.
And he wouldn't have turntables
on set.
But he would connect
his boom box to his phone
and start playing music
between takes.
And the whole crew loved it,
especially on, like,
late night shoots.
It would be 4:00 A.M.
and people are tired
and it keeps the energy up.
-And he's good at it?
He's a good deejay.
-He's great. And he also -- you
know, he sort of ad-libs too.
-He does like
the, "Yeah, come on!"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, right.
He's his own hype man.
-Yeah, he hypes up
the whole crew.
It was really fun.
So, then I figure, like,
that was a great thing to do
on a set.
And the next movie
I did after "Baby Driver"
was this movie
called "Jonathan."
And the first day
we were in a bar,
so I actually found, like,
these turntables and a cord
to plug my phone in.
And I figured it would have
a great sound system.
And I thought, "What would be a
fun song to play for the crew?"
And this is a morning shoot,
so it's a little early,
about 6:00 A.M.,
and I decided to play Haddaway,
"What is Love?" You know?
♪♪ What is love ♪♪
-Yeah sure.
♪♪ -Baby, don't -- ♪♪
So I plugged that in,
and I didn't quite turn
the sound down right away.
And it blasted ♪♪ What is love ♪♪
And the whole crew
starts looking, like,
"What's going on?"
The first A.D. is like,
"Where's that music coming from?
Where's that music coming from?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Oh, it's me. It's me."
They're like,
"Can you turn that off?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"I'm not Jamie Foxx."
-I think, yeah, in general,
for people like you and I,
don't ever try to do the things
Jamie Foxx is good at.
-No. I mean, I try.
-Yeah.
-I will continue to try to do
everything Jamie Foxx does.
-Hey, you gave six months
and you got that car.
Keep at this, too.
-Yeah.
-I'm doing to deejay
on every set I'm on.
Eventually it will work.